bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui
enes kanter freedom qui est un joueur de
basket professionnel pour l'équipe des
boston celtics
il est en déplacement avec son équipe et
il est avec nous depuis philadelphie
merci d'être avec nous je vous remercie
pour votre invitation marque
je ne veux pas tellement parler de
basket ball mais plutôt de votre
militantisme
ça fait depuis longtemps depuis des
années que vous dénoncez les violations
des droits de l'homme en chine
particulièrement vous avez récemment
critiqué la superstar du basket mondial
lebron james pour son silence
face aux violations des droits de
l'homme en chine et notamment contre la
minorité ouïghoure est ce que c'est
parce qu'il incarne d'une certaine façon
la nba ou est ce parce qu'il est le
représentant de nike ou alors allez vous
c'est important parce que cela dépasse
le basket il ya de très nombreuses
violations des droits de l'homme pas
seulement en turquie mais dans le monde
entier
évidemment la chine est tout en haut de
la liste alors j'essaie toujours de
faire de la sensibilisation sur ce qui
se passe dans le monde entier et vous
savez
pour répondre à votre question bien je
dirais les deux chaque année il y à des
milliards de dollars en jeu dans les
relations entre la nba et la chine et
dans l'âme dans le même temps nike le
plus gros sponsor de la nba et se
livrent à ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
esclavage moderne avec des ateliers de
misère en chine je crois que tout le
monde pas seulement moi mais tous les
athlètes les bons joueurs les mauvais
joueurs les joueurs importants les
joueurs moins important tout le monde
doit s'exprimer pour changer les choses
mais vous êtes l'un des seuls à dénoncer
cela et encore une fois lebron james les
autres superstars vous êtes un bon très
bon joueur mais vous n'êtes pas lebron
james pourquoi est ce que vous pensez
qu'il
ne critique pas est ce que c'est parce
qu'il n'y attache pas d'importance ou
est ce que c'est parce qu'ils ont leurs
intérêts commerciaux avec nike avec
d'autres grandes sociétés et que ça
pourrait leur causer du souci
vous savez je répète à ses joueurs la
chose suivante avant d'apposer votre
signature sur un document
à hauteur de plusieurs millions $ avec
une entreprise jeudi fait des recherches
apprenez des choses sur ces entreprises
parce qu'il ya tellement de violations
qui ont lieu dans une région qu'on
appelle le qinghai en chine
mais
bien sûr quand je discute avec des
athlètes il me répète qu'il y a
énormément d'activités d'argent en jeu
il a des contrats publicitaires il ya
des ventes de chaussures des ventes de
maillots en jeu les ventes en chine mais
je leur répète à chaque fois que vous
porter ces chaussures à chaque fois que
vous portez ces maillots
ces objets sont le fruit de tellement de
sang de sueur d'oppression je leur dis
toujours fait attention
alors vous n'intervenez pas que des
sportifs vous avez récemment interpellé
il à masquer
le milliardaire le fondateur de la
société tesla parce qu'il a apparemment
ouvert un show room dans la région du
xinjiang pour sa marque tesla et on peut
imaginer que hélène masse c'est
exactement ce qu'ils font
vous savez il y à une loi qui vient
d'être adoptée par le gouvernement baden
qui dit jeu les entreprises doivent
prouver qu'elles n'ont rien à voir avec
le travail forcé alors c'est une loi qui
est adopté il ya une dizaine de jours
est malheureusement
juste après l'adoption de cette joie il
ose musk a ouvert un showroom au
xinjiang
et je n'en croyais pas mes oreilles il
n'est pas possible qu'il joue soit
qu'ils ignorent ce qui se passe là-bas
où son entreprise l'ignorent savez la
chine utilise des moyens financiers pour
acheter le silence elle vient de
s'offrir et l'one
est ce que vous êtes en faveur on a vu
un mouvement de boycott diplomatique des
jeux olympiques d'hiver qui vont se
tenir en chine d'ici quelques semaines
mais c'est un boycott diplomatique les
états unis l'australie et la
grande-bretagne ne vont pas envoyer
d'officiel mais leurs athlètes vont
participer à la compétition est ce que
vous êtes déçu est ce que vous êtes en
faveur est ce que vous appeler à un
boycott complet et qu'en est il des
sponsors notamment les occidentaux qui
travaillent pour les jeux olympiques
alors tout d'abord évidemment ça a
commencé avec les états unis puis le
royaume-uni le canada certain nombre de
pays dont l'australie ont suivi
alors je crois que le boycott
diplomatique c'est bien mais que cela ne
suffit pas
il faut
des actes il faut agir
mais je pense que les athlètes doivent
s'exprimer et dire que ça suffit nous
devons faire entendre nos voix sur ce
sujet parce que ce sont les athlètes qui
pourront être facteur de changement
vous savez je comprends le point de vue
des gens
est-ce que vous pensez que que c'est
juste et ce qu'on nous dit des athlètes
qui ont travaillé toute leur vie pour
atteindre ce niveau et puis on leur dit
de ne pas y aller mais vous avez tous
ces athlètes voilà ce que je leur dis je
le redis toutes les médailles d'or que
vous pourriez remporter ne valent pas
autant que votre éthique que vos
principes que vos valeurs crois qu'il
faut se battre pour ce qui est juste et
il ya autre chose si vous êtes un
athlète eh bien il ya plein de jeunes
qui vous regardent qui suivent votre
exemple
et donc nous devons être de bons
exemples des modèles pour ces jeunes
et pour les entreprises bon je comprends
qu'il a énormément d'argent en jeu mais
à l'heure où on parle il ya un génocide
en cours donc je pense qu'il faut
adopter une position plus ferme
imaginons si des athlètes yvon est ce
que vous leur demandez peut-être quand
vous êtes là si c'est possible même si
c'est risqué vous devriez dire quelque
chose de la même façon que vous avez
parfois des slogans sur vos baskets pour
montrer comment ils se soucient de cette
chose
alors ce serait une excellente idée mais
il y a autre chose regardez ce que la
chine a fait à sa propre joueuse de
tennis
voilà ce que je répète lorsque je
parlais que seat est est-ce qu'on va
vraiment continuer à se sentir si bien
si on envoie nos athlètes dans un pays
comme la chine donc je crois qu'il faut
faire très très attention
j'aimerais maintenant parler de votre
pays d'origine la turquie votre
passeport a été révoqué il y a quelques
années vous avez été accusées
d'appartenir à un groupe terroriste en
raison de votre lien avec fethullah
gulen
qui vit en exil aux états unis et que le
régime erdogan accuse d'être derrière la
tentative de coup d'état en 2016
quelle est votre appréciation de la
situation des droits de l'homme en
turquie en ce moment
alors tout d'abord en ce qui concerne
monsieur bul n est bien la nuit du coup
d'état j'étais avec lui et j'ai vu sa
réaction de mes propres yeux il était
assis dans son fauteuil la prier pour
son pays ni lui ni ses partisans ni ces
étudiants n'ont été impliqué dans la
tentative de coup d'état donc le
président ado one man ensuite si on
s'intéresse à ce qui se passe en turquie
la turquie est le pays qui emprisonne le
plus ses journalistes dans le monde est
tout simplement parce que je me suis
exprimé librement mon passeport a été
révoqué mon nom a été placé sur la liste
d'interpol mon père a été arrêté une
descente a été menée chez moi il ya
tellement de prisonniers politiques dans
ce pays aujourd'hui qui ont besoin
d'être aidés
et je crois que si on suit ce qui se
passe au moyen-orient
on a une bonne idée du genre de
personnes qui errent doan il a menacé
toute l'europe avec la crise des
réfugiés
et on peut dire qu'ils gouvernent son
pays comme un chef mafieux
mais je sens que l'union européenne que
les etats unis doivent intervenir faire
quelque chose agir car la turquie joue
un rôle essentiel pour le moyen-orient
pour l'europe et donc il faut faire
quelque chose et que faut-il faire ce
que vous appelez un changement de régime
ou est ce que vous appelez un processus
électoral normal pour choisir son leader
je crois que des élections normales ne
mènerait à rien carrère douanes d'une
manière ou d'une autre s'arrangerait
pour les remporter je crois qu'il
volerait les voies et que d'une manière
ou d'une autre ils les reporterait et
que même s'il perdait il ne l'est
compterait pas regarder ce qui s'est
passé il ya trois ans avec les élections
municipales il a perdu mais la
comptabilisation n'a pas été
fait et on à organiser de nouvelles
élections
mais la turquie était une démocratie
avance et un pays pacifique l'économie
marchait bien et regardez ce qu'est
devenue la turquie la turquie aurait pu
être un pont entre l'islam et l'occident
mais ce n'est pas possible aujourd'hui
avec ce qui se passait donc oui il faut
un changement de régime car avec un
changement de régime la turquie pourrait
essayer de se relever de redevenir un
pays démocratique mais sous la dictature
d'ardoyne c'est impossible
dernière question vous avez décidé de
devenir citoyen américain vous avez
changé votre nom de haine et scooters à
enescu hunter freedom liberté donc c'est
évidemment un choix important pourquoi
l'avoir fait
vous savez ce mot est très important
pour moi parce qu'il y a tellement de
prisonniers politiques détenus en chine
en turquie mais pas seulement également
dans le monde entier et donc pour moi ce
mot revêtent une importance toute
particulière
je veux le porter partout où je vais je
veux que les enfants fassent des
recherches sur leur propre nom de
famille pour voir ce qu'il veut dire
vous savez j'ai voulu devenir un citoyen
américain parce que aux états unis il ya
des règles des lois des contre-pouvoirs
si vous critiquez le gouvernement vous
n'allez pas être emprisonné votre
passeport ne va pas être révoqué vous
votre nom ne va pas être inscrits sur
une liste d'interpol et donc je crois
que ce nom a une signification
essentielle
je suis très fier de l'avoir adopté
l'aîné scooter freedom merci beaucoup
d'avoir été l'invitée de france 24 merci
à vous de l'avoir regardé rester sur
france 24 pour plus d'informations
[Musique]